no good McKee with the board two seconds
to go James a buzzer beater
[Applause]
which is it
and nails at LeBron James closes out the
first half with a 40-footer
[Music]
being able to grab those offensive long
rebounds you can play great defense and
they're just times where offensively the
preganant his career he was the starting
on opening night then throws it back out
really turned over mix Carter saves it
shot clock down to five marquita gets up
on prince and some of the best hustle
and we've seen her in the harbor t feet
away maybe a little new products folks
see threes made and attempted still
alive picked up by English final seconds
bingos at the buzzer
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a third phone around Ingolstadt
with 22 we still have a quarter to go
and set by lowering into the paint 78
for Damian little fighters from way
downtown
let's look out the Damien
towards nowhere close he's going in
defenders coming in for Chicago
got it - JJ walk free
[Applause]
not meeting could do that
[Music]
with down by three that could tie the
game with seven with six and here's
LeBron LeBron for the time of the
evening than LeBron with the clock
winding down long three-pointer calmly
knocks nice are they your speed a bit
game there of course twenty-eight
[Music]
[Applause]
they're right up on him any swishes what
do you do
[Applause]
I'm not moving for them the event must
be greater than
[Applause]
unlimited range why isn't someone
crowding him making foot on the floor I
know it
[Applause]
[Music]
they're really cracking down on that one
talented thanks it in for three at the
buzzer comes curry
warrior shooting 60% of the team
it's a ridiculous one a record you see
this three little push-off a bomb with a
hand in the face his 7th straight game
with five or more threes made a new NBA
record for Steph Curry is to play on the
half for Reggie Jackson turns fires
fills
three from the sideline with eight
tenths of a second to play in the half
our students 56 here we go he thought
maybe big Robert Williams should have
been called for the foul in Boston
[Applause]
virginity turn in fire
1:10 apiece 20 seconds left two seconds
Paul the pull-up
one point sixty point half are you
talking gotta try to slow down Conley
lost the dribble O'Neill stands in his
way
what's all baked at home Wow I think
this is gonna count got a shooter what
are you trying to do let's forget that
see those can see what's happening there
now you got a choice one phone beep let
it go and if there's anybody who can
avoid it from me
[Applause]
it is Jim Crawford donate $100 to some
charities on the cropper three there's
two point four to play in the bird sang
in the horn for Tyler Johnson goes
[Music]
Johnson to win bound it baked it in a
three at the buzzer mutton Andre
Drummond at his place quarterback is the
DeGeorge sends Georgie a half-court shot
all season now down the buzzer-beating
truth Wow Eagles up on Luca Jazz and a
foul again
[Applause]
they gave it to
he gave it to and closed it for the
second quart out the way they did
they're going to be in control eight for
14 from the three-point line
Luka adding two men from the three-point
line and hanging out with the so Dupree
set to 14 now at eight Williams defended
by Forbes
[Applause]
[Music]
29 feet away and he gives his team the
lead 40 seconds to go buzzer and then
the unlikely TJ Warren with it
Cameron Payne he fires manic ahead
welcome that's a story for Cameron Payne
[Applause]
and that's gonna count for three three
that will count 96 87 6 years after
three the 4th quarter coming up outside
Vienna turns fires
[Applause]
with 2.6 seconds to play go look down
with the Pistons have a two-point lead
to lead the rocket 98-96 a clutch triple
for Blake Griffin that's what great
scores do they can bail you out
Lillard a very deep three once they warm
up tonight humanity shooting further
than I've ever seen him I'd made a
comment we talked bleep licked his arm
James pull up for a three here it comes
and there it goes splash very reluctant
to take it but he made it pray from just
inside puts it down good job by the
greeter denying siak of Kyle
bucket and pumpkin tip away but like he
said quality got to get a quality shot
Dan outside of three
[Applause]
[Music]
between defenders Springs for three it
happened when Avery Bradley was in the
game he changed the officials about it
[Applause]
[Music]
Lucca dodges with about what was an a
40-footer the second is last holiday and
eco on the fly by he'll get it up in
time
[Applause]
to finish the third quarter of the sixth
another one of your own and that's from
Dave Dixon drive oh yes three for the
Warriors are done by coasting as we head
and bull wrapping around guarded by
Hollis Jefferson here's Jackson jr. a
three is good and it's time deja vu in
the worst way
the nets are out of timeouts
Wyles three-pointer and he answers with
a triple at the gun Northwestern
Wildcats took on the Ohio State Buckeyes
down say goodnight
Lakers are on their way to a win over
the Mavericks he's just saying I'm gonna
set us come said nah just stay there let
me shoot this hood from about 30 feet
physical to get it to compel underneath
again but cuttings been able to take it
away Wiggins came in there though and
knocked them off and to let it fly the
buzzer did the Timberwolves need that
certainly did two seconds one second
[Applause]
the clock retains a deep three
[Applause]
basically taking it in the teeth Matt
Fraser may have got away with a walk at
the buzzer did they ever need it 33 for
Irving 34 for wall he'll take a long
three believable Kyrie Irving his fourth
three-pointer of the game has to give up
the dribble shot clock to three crucial
lost control has to heave it
[Applause]
who's done her with that incredible
he's with the shot clock running down on
that plate both guys were determined to
get a play for their team hardly
[Applause]
[Music]
it has been incredible you remember the
Hackett deandre days
the bridge is lost it fall to the floor
Michael has it temple got a pull-up
[Applause]
Augustine with five to shoot
gonna have to Harry gets the shot off
van a days in DJ Augustine Dante Exum
who's done a nice job off the bench play
making and playing defenses in team
three by CJ McCollum at three touchdowns
two seconds to go in the quarter
here comes rivers can't get in the world
[Applause]
10 0 ii 71 points to the Chazz here put
shower tea for people 3 goes agree
that's the first thing that twin writes
for the Knicks in the first half Cardon
backs up tries it again
James earn eight points by Hartman's
at 34 to 20 quarters and the Rockets you
can see why this is a good defensive
team right here they're very aggressive
yes they are
Wow
[Applause]
25 seconds
how about that shot in brown harden
trying to get three down to three down
to territory
James Harden of flamethrower incredible
shot James Harden with two warriors and
draped on him
why's the one to get this to go down and
easily could have been fouled in the
grill of draymond Green
a former Defensive Player of the Year
deep freeze while we baked it in
The Legend of Luca continuing to be
written for the rookie smart toppling
off as he contested that was clearly a
foul
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my goodness look at Chris Don's
franks and rudy Gay can live there um
he's been hurt son but like it at the
great finish that time by yo Luka he
practices that stuff ah here we go no
time outs for the Mets they've got to
have a three
there's dimwitty putting it up
[Applause]
Kairi a bomb
[Applause]
big time shot maker great contest by
Leonard 9 104 and we flip a quarter to
play curry launches again down take
Sexton takes the jumper
[Applause]
your first half Terry Rozier pushes it
firing
[Applause]
watch Oh the dump inside winterling
handsome levels desperation three
goodness decided he was gonna be the guy
the last shots for the patients in the
hand
[Music]
[Applause]
d-doc Santino Chris hard to guard them
once you got put space he clears and
Sumner tries to get up and you got to
remember he can still handle a ball so
he can get to the front of the rim
this birds couple of in the opening
moments of the game
[Music]
[Applause]
and that baby was needed there's Don
ships thought about sue to the three
shot clock winding down as dodge fires
intense heat shrugs his shoulders the
Warriors to eight points here in the
fourth quarter which with by far be a
season low
Lillard from D Kenneth gets over
good morning and in thanks to guys like
Larry Bird it up and others for showing
us
let's go
[Applause]
Russell was the cross-court
[Music]
[Applause]
to each other
[Applause]
this is how the rest of the leaf and
I'll have to explain that later class
was trying to get him on the Rockets for
next season no no he was trying to get
him into 300 what a three that's have
attempted 34 threes God look at the and
then look at this I'm gonna be really
honest I don't think I've ever in my
life hit a shot from that far back let
alone just kind of a
[Applause]
yeah 33 footer I mean he's out there 40
feet ray was 7 6 trains gonna launch
from deep it looks like yep there it
comes
[Applause]
get water check it out
you gotta make them like that I'd shoot
the bar anytime I get it I did your
favor and change Facebook no no Luc
Renard it's 43 and Counting and deeper
and deeper we go five to shoot for
Portland
[Applause]
goodness he shot that from Durham
lets you know how high-level his skill
is staunch hitch
[Applause]
a half-court jump shot from Luca Dutch
Luke Bernard somewhere to going advice
Andre on top the fire a [ __ ] off the
window
get it free like the ballgame
Minneapolis put these guys away thought
Victor has ranged we've got tapped
outside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Timbo's get the stop kata pasty up
showing some deep fence here comes tiga
lets it fly
Jane drills it from just inside midcourt
shortened on a three there's a foul to
give
Drummond will get it to Galloway that's
on deep Langston Galloway at the horn
Damion Lee comes in for the first time
curry and green return Harden
step back it's bad one chance for a
four-point play is hard knocks down his
first three-pointer of the game but how
about the kind of separation Mike he
gets with that step back another second
maybe off the clock got a foul widely
found Jackson for the tie why didn't
they foul one point one to play crews
not calling that five to shoot Lillard
that is a bomb
which companies using out of his be said
set it he waited for McGee and he did it
now they back to you that's gonna count
perhaps now look at it right at the
buzzer to end the third quarter
seven seconds on the shot clock
[Music]
are you kidding me
[Applause]
from circulating well this church
super-mo will show you that he's at
least 10 feet behind that oh my goodness
hurry puts it on the deck his floater no
rebound Holliday two seconds
[Applause]
Toki's got to get it up watch it Wow a
lot of contact
hurry pulls up for the three and of
course he makes it how does he do it
knee sprain is a holding his foot
how does he do it because he's Steph
Curry
see how as you're watching it fly to the
ball Jazza miss her last five shots it
close out the third
females at 3:00 at the horn get us
updated on that it's Troy Daniels
working a little sink in bang dropping
the lon right booted out the Mavericks
with an opportunity to time Rd a two
point lead
it's Burke stepping into the three at
the end of the face from Ferguson and he
buries it
David Nawab on the floor defending
Booker drops it up the bridge he's hit
two three seconds four point one who's
gonna be like with our guy that's doctor
right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]